the other day on my birthday March 20th
happy birthday Jimmy thank you to
everyone who wished me happy birthday
I'm loving it being 25 really loving it
but it was quite a gift with all of the
announcements they've announced new
spring watch bands and they also
announced a pink sand charging case and
I made a video previously talking about
these charging cases actually make two
videos because I'm that obsessed I think
it's one of those things where I had
never used a charging case for so long
that I forgot how amazing it is now it
does add a little bit of size you can
see your phone foreshore this is
everything I don't even know what the
kids say that all the time and I don't
even sure what that even means look this
is everything is this everything does
this mean everything to me
does this mean is it everything like
what does that even mean but the pink
sand is one of my favorite colors it has
been one of my favorite cases and I have
the gold phone so this pink sand case
always looked so great this was one of
the things that I completely missed the
day that they had all of those
announcements until every single one of
you guys were tweeting me this asking if
I got it and didn't even know was a
thing I completely missed it well let's
open this up I'd also love to have my
sister come up and talk about her case
if you guys remember I surprised her
with it get out of here get out of your
home
also a surprise to my sister I'm wearing
one of our shirts right now so sure
she'll notice as soon as she pokes here
it is pinks and get out of there come on
out join the family so one of the things
I've loved so much about these cases is
that honestly I can get through a whole
day plus and not even think about my
phone dying at all it's not even a
thought any longer this is such a
beautiful phone it's so great okay all
right
still it's a pretty light color I mean
it matches my sister's shirt and
everything
hey Jana bring your phone who she has
the case on it that's really gonna ruin
it feet the purpose oh hi oh oh I just
got blinded I like it I used it for my
video and I have the light blue oh I bet
you every color for like each video so
it's like super unique cool I use blue
okay I don't think I've used blue yet I
may have I'm not sure mm anyway
where's your charging case charging
turns it tied Shelly the whole reason
that I brought you up here let's talk
about the case it's okay I mean we know
you've had is charging I surprised you
with it I love it
I use it all the time but I actually
don't charge my phone I just use that
and I charge that so you just start to
wait you take your phone out of the case
charge the case and then put the phone
in at the time look what I'm going to
bed like my phone is charged so I'm like
okay cool so I'll take the case out
charge the case because why would I keep
charging my phone that's already had a
hundred percent that's valid is it that
makes sense see I just don't ever have
to charge anything because it's just
fully charged always well I like I mean
it's like 10 o'clock o'clock screw the
show make videos every day
so yeah
that's why I get it but I think it's so
cool this is also wireless charging -
yes and like when I use it in my car I
plug it in like it works with my car
play changing my car play mostly because
it reads our text messages but it
because it's like girl what smiling face
Justine poop emoji girl raising hand
maybe percent man with mustache but
other than that yeah I know our lovely
it's actually my favorite case I really
like it I love the two keeps my phone
charged I'm always using my phone I'm so
wonderful except do you want to go get
it no I think we know what it looks like
it's serving she has a black version
remember I surprised you do something to
me no here put this in your hand see if
you can guess what it is it's rubbery
okay so yeah but what kind a charger one
pink looks good matches your sweater
matches your sweater is nice why don't
pick this one we need to repair you
picked another picture and I said you
can't with this we're gonna be my
favorite sweater I'm running out of
clothes to wear go lastly I just keeps
doing yours this is mine but I got it
back from your closet I always thought
that was mine no it was just in your
closet for the longest time so that's
the rule you have to keep it are you
running this over top of a t-shirt oh I
got pole so yeah I wasn't filming
anymore you look good good cool but
shirt um okay that's it I just wanted to
show them who hey and I want to get an
update to see if you're still in here I
am it's literally charging downstairs
I'm sorry I forgot that's work it's okay
up here for that's okay oh it does the
fact that my phone is where charging
isn't messing it up I don't know that
was somebody that somebody asked me as
well and I don't have an answer because
they've always had problems I just
always have problems let's I don't know
I just don't want to like mess
but why would they make that if that
would mess it up I don't know in regard
I am unsure well thanks for joining us
thank you for having me
yes Beauty you have to get a guest stole
it felt nice am I going too cheap so I'm
gonna go cheaper so I didn't like it
Wiggly thank you sir has me and you're
welcome okay I just have to show you
this and also give you an update on how
much Jena is obviously loving hers she
loves it so much is even had on her
phone but that's only because she has it
charger you guys haven't subscribed to
my channel already make sure you hit
that subscribe button and hit the like
button if you liked the video I will
have more fun videos coming up for you
very shortly like always I don't know
I'm not sure depends how fast I can edit
later bye
[Music]